ich habe den eindruck dass du dich
wingst stimmt das aber nein die leute
schreiben dann sowas wie es kay warum
spielst du dich du [ __ ]
das ist mit dem verkehr
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft bierhoff
meine tiefpunkt netz.com und die heutige
challenge lautet die alles umsonst
challenge die sieht vor dass sie jedes
mal kurz bevor ich ein modul beende das
heißt kurz bevor ich auf dem gelben
block bin so wie hier wenn ich einen
blog von gelben block bin muss ich mich
in den abgrund stürzen
alles war umsonst und ich muss es von
vorne machen und das bei jedem modul das
heißt es wird eine richtig richtig
knackige challenge der nicht wert
schwierigkeiten haben erst mal die ganz
schwierigen modul am ende zu packen die
man vielleicht nur einmal in seinem
ganzen leben schafft und dann zweimal in
einer runde ist schwierig wenn man dann
einmal im ganzen leben weil da müsste
man ja sterben und sich wieder beleben
und ein neues leben haben und dann wisst
ihr ich bin so spitze bin ich jetzt
wieder hier am gelben block und es geht
wieder und wieder von vorne alter
schwede diese change wird jetzt noch
ganz lustig sein aber später wenn ich
dann weiter fortgeschritten bin in der
runde wird mich das richtig nerven
kosten denn ich kenne diese momente man
hat irgendwie so ein modul muss ich so
denkt so nein ich hasse dieses modul und
dann schafft man es doch irgendwie und
stadt immer vor wie bitter muss das sein
wenn ich nachher in diesem video einfach
an so eine stelle komme eine stelle
kommen wo ich dann einfach gerade so
dieses modul geschafft hat was ich
eigentlich sonst nie schaffe und dann
musste ich anstatt ins ziel laufen zu
können und mit dem verdienten checkpoint
abzuholen muss ich einfach mich
unterstützen wie ich hier die ganze
schon freiwillig mache das war so bitter
alter ich hoffe dass einfach keine allzu
schwierigen par kurs kommen hier sonst
bin ich richtig richtig am rating
garantiert habe ich mich schon unter
gestürzt ja habe ich glaube ich okay
jetzt habe ich ihn mitnehmen nächste den
trend sieht ganz gut aus leute guckt mal
wir sind laser kempter rechts und wir
sind auf platz drei trotz unserer
challenge also wir laufend wegen dieser
challenge eigentlich alles doppelt müsst
euch mal so vorstellen sagt und werden
wieder ein blogger vorberg wir laufen
alles doppelt trotzdem waren wir
zumindest gerade im auf platz zwei
vielleicht sogar auf platz 3 gerade mal
wild bisschen platt drais mehr als zwei
deswegen das platz drei mehr als platz
zwei okay die change weshalb ich
verwechsle die ganze zeit challenge und
module man ich muss echt ein bisschen
mehr nachdenken
dann plappert er mir so vor sich hin
okay dass da wir das mitnehmen glaube
ich
das generell alles mitnimmt irgendwie
habe ich noch ein bisschen abgespeichert
dass ich eigentlich sein equipment
challenge heute habe aber habe ich gar
nicht okay
das könnte schon das erste training
werden dann ich sag mal hier lang
das wird richtig schwierig machen
das ist schon wieder so ein blog sprung
ich mag diese einem blog sprünge
eigentlich gar nicht so gerne
also diese sprünge wo man von einem
block aus ohne anlauf zu nehmen
einen ganz weiten sprung machen muss
diese maximaldistanz das ist eigentlich
mehr oder weniger meine schwäche in
minecraft anblick aber ich sag trotzdem
mal dass wir das hinbekommen 2000 jahre
später
okay da ist jetzt das kann man hier für
tricks machen erwarte man kann kann man
hier so vielleicht so drauf springt ja
neuesten trick gucke ich bin ein doktor
vor bergab backup backup backup backup
und jetzt habe ich wieder von vorne
sehr schön aber immerhin habe ich jetzt
einen trick dafür who sehr gut jetzt nur
noch einmal hier hoch schillig und dann
hier rüber und das einfach noch mal
machen weiter nach hinten
ja ja okay jetzt gesagt jetzt
durchziehen
jaja und den checkpoint dankeschön ich
darf noch einmal eine kiste in dieser
runde mitnehmen alter sehr geil
ok aktionisten kisten die wo man es
jetzt so was von dir ist wirklich hart
verdient okay jetzt einen trailer ganz
nah im vergleich zu letzten es einfach
so viel leichter und wieder runter sagt
dieser physics diesem trend nicht machen
der ist natürlich verpflichtend wenn man
den auslässt dann gibt es punktabzug
-100 für hockey awards gibt dann niemand
will - 100 für hockenheim zu riskieren
das modul ging es wieder recht gut dass
hier geht eigentlich auch das ist eins
von den ganz alten das ist dieser
brunner und in die kiste ist hier ja das
ist ein ganz altes modell ok sehr schön
ich bin aber noch nicht ganz vorne ich
muss jetzt erst wieder direkt bis ein
blog for safe point und dann wieder
runter job nein nein das dass das zählt
jetzt nicht leute das ziel hat sich war
nicht bis einen blog vor dem checkpoint
ich muss jetzt noch mal hin noch mal hin
und dann nochmal
jetzt hier war okay und runter 13
sekunden gebraucht wenn ich jetzt auf
andy packe kann ich es noch mal schaffen
dann hätten wir immerhin wie viele
module
ich glaube bis zu den haag modulen sind
wir nicht gekommen aber hey leute
immerhin also ich fand wir haben uns
dieser change richtig gut geschlagen bis
auf diese eine modul das hat viel zeit
gekostet aber können wir jetzt hier noch
die chest mitnehmen bitte bitte bitte
bitte ja ich sag mal können mit dem sehr
schön
ok erstmal alles aussortieren gut so
werden der eisenachs wir haben hier
unsere angel
damit können jetzt die spielleiter sei
die stadt nicht kaputt gemacht denn mein
kopf romans den hier den anbieter eine
sache die ich noch ansprechen wollte
übrigens ich habe in letzter zeit
irgendwie öfters mit mit max und anderen
youtube darüber geredet wir wissen
verwirrt ist das richtig oft leute unter
meine videos schreiben eske ey du
schwimmst dich oder sowas oder noch
krasser dann würdest du erwarten dass
die leute so schreiben wenn sie
vernünftig werden
dann will man erwarten dass ich
vielleicht sagen ja es kay ich habe den
eindruck dass wir die schmink stimmt das
aber nein die leute schreiben die dann
so was wie es kay warum spielst du dich
du [ __ ] nicht das ist mit der
verkehrt junge also erstens schminke ich
mich nicht die einzige ursache dafür
dass es so aussieht als würde ich mich
schminken oder so aussehen könnte ist
dass ich einfach die augenringe of doom
ab weil ja viel zu wenig schlaf weil ich
vollzeit arbeitet nebenbei noch jeden
tag ein video produzieren
und dazu habe ich was war bei uns aber
eine familie liegt relativ lange wimpern
das haben bei uns eine familie aber alle
ich verstehe einfach die menschen nicht
in den schreiben so du schwimmst du
[ __ ] oder oder du siehst aus wie
eine frau nicht so dass ich dass mich
das traurig machen würde oder so
versteht mich nicht falsch machen wir
jetzt genau mich weil ich premium apa
der premium hater wir kennen sie alle
offen ist jetzt ein anderer das aber
auch im prämie meter habe ich hab was
drin ich kann bisschen rumlaufen hat
noch bereich du mir das wäre ich an zu
essen jetzt ein bisschen raus da kam ich
auch keiner festnahme so dahin kommt und
jana was sagt ihr noch mal hallo
es ist so sinnlos ebit von hinten
geschlagen geht immer noch auf mich kein
wunder dass man drauf geht also ganz
ehrlich oder kommt noch einer alter ich
bin ich gefragt ihr hätten darunter
mitgefühl und er läuft volle reihen
alter rasse der ist noch geschwächt
jetzt regel mannheim drehung dreh
umdrehung bis lo que macht diesen antrag
aber der aber gar nicht so schlecht
fasst funktioniert 3 warum gebt mir
meinen hintern fliegt er zu mir dann
kann ich den easy abstauben
oh lola der funktioniert alter dafür die
szene leder risse hat ist er ziemlich
unbekannt sein
ok jetzt kriegt er noch einige sagt zack
zack zack zack ich hab ihn champion so
den den hab ich jetzt hole ich mir auch
den hier beim bam bam bam so und noch
einer sehr schön aber er hat jetzt nicht
doch der den bogen geil ich hatte
einfach kein bogen pfeile aber keinen
bogen
ohne wird sie haben drei leben wir haben
so viel leben wir unsere beiden gegnern
zusammen
und das obwohl wir jeden einzelnen
parcours doppelt laufen mussten das ist
eigentlich richtig richtig gut aber es
muss wir gucken dass wir uns nicht so
auf den keks geht den will ich ganz
gerne wahr wegklatschen diesen typen ja
okay das war nicht schlau von ihm ja
okay jetzt kommt nämlich der hier jetzt
beiden hingegeben diesen beide
geschwächt er kriegt noch ein hol ich
mir den hole ich mir den hole ich mir
okay hat nur noch ein leben so jetzt
gehst du dich auch runter und jetzt
gehen wir an jemand die exakt 66 exakt
oben unten links rechts hatte sich
ausgeloggt die bitter warum lockt man
sich aus habe ich ein problem problem zu
wollen wir wollen nach leben ja da hat
mich darauf mich mist mist da war diese
blöden zone etwas sage ich wir wollen
auch leben
ich hab doch noch zwei leben ändern auch
ein leben ich habe zwei leben die runde
werde ich mir holen wenn ich jetzt hier
wegklatschen zero mein leben verläuft da
hinten weg laufe ich hier oben rein
ich sag ja da ist das schon klasse
er wollte ich hinten und klatschen aber
ich gebe ihm erst mal schön die first
suites und dann gleichmäßig jetzt
gegeben und damit ohne gewonnen leute
sehr schön für diese knackige change
wirklich gut geschlagen wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten video wieder haut
rein macht's gut und übrigens am sonntag
kommt natürlich wieder eine folge hacker
schau also bleibt gespannt